what do you have to do when you're
meeting the people at Marvel to impress
them enough to get such a gig just say
yes so he asked everything just yeah
it's not yeah absolutely I can do that
right um I won't let you down with
writing my advice that no one ever takes
is take as long as you can to write and
for the little people I wrote the first
draft in may be 2004. we shot that in
2015.
you do the math what we do in the
shadows Jermaine and other way that we
work we end we would end up like doing
maybe a page a year and then we ended up
with 150 pages so it took 150 years to
write the script I don't anything anyone
actually says I'm going to make a movie
where the theme is about Bloody blah
blah theme is something that comes later
once you've finished the film and then
some nerdy film student goes I think the
thing is about loyalty and then you go
yeah totally I was totally thinking
about loyalty when I made this